Samsung vient de lancer sa nouvelle
expérience logiciel pour l'année 2000
fan 2022 2023 on va se dire ça comme ça
c'est one uye 5 cinquième version de one
uye avec plein de nouveautés j'ai
identifié 15 nouveaux teint
intéressantes ils ont des tailles un
paquet de plus mais j'en ai 15 qui sont
extrêmement intéressantes on va regarder
ensemble quels sont ces 15 nouveautés et
vous allez voir qu'elle se déploie elles
sont en train de se déployer ici sur un
Samsung Galaxy S22 ultra si vous avez
des S22 vous pourrez probablement déjà
la voir et bien évidemment surtout les
anciens modèles les autres modèles de
Samsung donc regardez sur votre
smartphone si vous pouvez venir faire la
mise à jour d'ailleurs pour faire la
mise à jour c'est très simple vous venez
ici dans vos paramètres vous avez tout
en bas dans mise à jour du logiciel et
vous venez regarder si vous avez la
dernière mise à jour moi je l'ai faite
voyez j'ai la dernière mise à jour vous
allez sur téléchargement et installation
et ça vous regardera s'il y a une mise à
jour disponible pour venir installer ou
un ui 5 et ça c'est chouette allez vous
êtes prêt on y va
[Musique]
premier point ce sont de nouvelles
icônes et des meilleures illustrations
graphiques alors ici j'ai rien vu de
bien bien notable effectivement 10
secondes qui sont annoncés comme étant
un peu plus grandes ok des meilleurs
animations au-delà de ça c'est pas
extrêmement flagrant des effets de flou
et des couleurs améliorés ok c'est ce
qu'annonce Samsung bon c'est pas le
point le plus important mais je me
devais quand même de vous en parler ça
commence à être beaucoup plus
intéressant quand on arrive sur le
deuxième point c'est le côté
personnalisation et notamment au niveau
de votre écran ici vous voyez je vais
avoir des trucs hyper cool je peux venir
totalement le personnaliser ça c'est
très très chouette personnalisé
l'horloge même personnalisée un petit
message en bas regardez je suis monsieur
greu pour mon capteur d'empreintes
digitale on connaît j'ai mon horloge mes
notifications et mon fond d'écran donc
le truc est très très cool ce qu'il faut
faire ici vous laissez appuyer ça vous
demande de les verrouiller hop là 14
empreinte digitale et là vous avez plus
qu'à choisir alors déjà votre fond
d'écran ça peut être un fond d'écran
vidéo ça peut être de la photo il y a
pas mal de possibilités voir également
vous dans votre galerie que vous voulez
vous avez aussi graphique moi j'en ai
choisi un graphique et que je trouvais
très très joli il y a des couleurs il y
en a différents donc à vous de faire
votre choix ici ça s'est très très
simple et ensuite lorsque vous revenez
ici vous pouvez moduler au niveau de
votre horloge alors aussi bien au niveau
du style de l'horloge allez vous en avez
plusieurs ici là qui sont quand même
plutôt sympa comme ça sur la gauche très
centrée avec l'horloge comme ça avec
différentes finitions avec les chiffres
sans les chiffres personnellement moi je
bien seul là je trouve très sympa je
peux également venir moduler la couleur
alors je peux le mettre il y a plein de
couleurs attention il y a des trucs qui
vont vraiment être pas du tout lisible
moi ce que je fais c'est que j'appuie
tout au fond regardez juste ici et là je
viens choisir et je mets un petit gris
vous voyez légèrement cassé comme ça
c'est pas mal ça me fait un côté un peu
grisé qui est très sympa autre chose je
peux venir moduler si au niveau de mes
notifications savoir si je veux les
icônes uniquement ou si je veux le
détail bon à vous de voir en fonction de
ce qui va vous intéresser si vous
choisissez avec le détail peut venir
également moduler la transparence soit
on voit quelque chose soit on voit rien
du tout soit on a un petit fond après
vous le mettez comme vous voulez
personnellement je préfère les icônes
uniquement c'est très épuré après vous
pouvez venir aussi inverser
automatiquement les couleurs si vous
mettez le détail comme ça bon voilà moi
une fois de plus je suis team icon et
après vous pouvez venir rajouter un
petit message ici alors petit message il
vous le mette ça peut être des
coordonnées ça peut être un email si
jamais vous perdez votre numéro de
téléphone ça peut être un petit message
ça peut être ce que vous voulez donc moi
j'ai mis je suis monsieur gros résultat
assez rigolo également les icônes en bas
vous pouvez venir modifier les petits
raccourcis alors mettre une calculatrice
d'enregistreur vocale la lampe torche ne
pas déranger et différentes applications
que vous allez retrouver personnellement
je laisse les appels je laisse
l'appareil photo ça me convient bien
donc vous voyez ça donne un résultat qui
est très sympa qui est très différent
alors on aurait pu vouloir aller un peu
plus loin et avoir la possibilité
d'enregistrer différents comme on a sur
iOS aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
néanmoins c'est déjà bien c'est un pas
en avant que nous fait ici Samsung ça
c'est chouette donc tac vous le
retrouvez là et après vous venez
déverrouiller vous arrivez directement
là alors là vous pouvez venir également
moduler votre fond d'écran personnalisé
faire comme vous voulez de la même
manière vous avez plus de palettes de
couleurs et beaucoup plus de choix ça
effectivement ça met d'Android 13 ça
c'est plutôt cool au niveau des fonds et
au niveau des couleurs de base bon
l'idée c'est matérial il est où qui a
évolué sur Android 13 si vous allez
suivi l'évolution d'Android 13 vous avez
déjà vu ça d'ailleurs je vous ai fait
une vidéo pour vous parler d'Android 13
je vous invite à venir la voir parce que
bon ça c'est purement l'Android 13e
astuce qui est très sympa au niveau de
la personnalisation vous pouvez venir
mettre un fond d'écran spécial quand
quelqu'un va vous appeler si par exemple
c'est votre mère vous pouvez mettre la
tête de votre mère si par exemple c'est
votre cop ma copine vous pouvez mettre
sa photo bref vous pouvez venir tout
personnaliser là-dessus ça vous évite de
voir le nom si elle est posée de loin
vous voyez la photo c'est pratique c'est
sympa et ça marche bien quatrième
nouveauté qui est vachement bien ce sont
les modes et routines alors regardez je
vous montre vous venez ici vous allez
dans vos paramètres et vous allez juste
ici là au niveau des modes et routines
ça c'est une nouveauté c'est très très
cool en fait c'est un peu la même chose
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui sur iOS et de
se dire ok je veux prendre du temps pour
dormir je ne serai pas dérangé personne
ne pourra m'appeler on est également un
mode exercé sur du sport de la détente
du travail moi c'est plutôt un mode
tournage vous dites par exemple j'en
sais rien moi le mode sommeil allez hop
la clique on vient l'activer là vous
dites allez de telle heure à telle heure
je dors et je ne serai pas dérangé quel
jour ok vous choisissez ce qui se
passera donc ici bah en fonction ne pas
déranger appelle les messages rien est
autorisé notification des applications
rien n'est autorisé après si vous voulez
vraiment que quelqu'un puisse vous
appeler lorsque vous dormez parce que
vous avez une crainte vous appuyez ici
vous venez ajouter un contact quelqu'un
d'important qui pourra venir vous
joindre si jamais il y a un problème si
ça peut vous rassurer il y a également
notre mode qui est intéressant c'est le
mode conduite ce qui fait que lorsque
vous allez prendre votre téléphone et
arriver dans une voiture il le verra
lorsqu'il est connecté à un appareil
Bluetooth en ce qui est connecté à votre
voiture et il va passer directement en
mode conduite et vous pouvez définir des
paramètres comme vous voulez ici je vous
montre par exemple moi j'ai créé mon
mode tournage donc là il est pas activé
mes voyages hop là je viens de l'activer
ne pas déranger rien n'est autorisé mais
je peux venir choisir que quelqu'un
puisse m'appeler par exemple je dis que
il y a uniquement Justine qui pourra
m'appeler à ce moment-là ok ça marche je
peux également venir activer les appels
récurrents si quelqu'un sait de
m'appeler plusieurs fois pendant 15
minutes et bien ça va prendre son appel
on glisse quelque chose d'urgent les
messages aucun message ou alors on peut
dire qu'on a des messages des contacts
uniquement des contacts favoris
uniquement ou alors absolument aucun
voyez on peut venir personnaliser comme
on veut en fonction des différents modes
mode travail ça pourrait être que votre
patron il veut différents collaborateurs
de votre boîte qui vous appelle le mode
détente ça peut être que quelqu'un
d'extrêmement important bref vous
choisissez vous personnaliser le truc
est très cool et c'est une belle avancée
que nous a mis Samsung ici autre
nouveauté on va la retrouver au niveau
des widgets sur l'écran d'accueil
regardez la voyez j'ai un widget qui est
là la regarder hop je change j'ai mon
horloge hop je change j'ai le jeu Dino
de chrome alors le truc en fait qui est
pas mal c'est qu'on peut créer des piles
au lieu d'avoir un widget là un autre ou
jet d'à côté encore un autre widget et
des tonnes de widgets dont on se servira
GL pas tout le temps ça prend beaucoup
de place sur l'écran et là vous venez
créer des piles alors le truc est très
très cool vous avez juste regardé là par
exemple je laisse appuyer je fais
modifier la pile donc là j'ai mes trois
widgets ma météo mon horloge et mon jeu
Dino je peux venir en supprimer je peux
venir en rajouter un j'appuie ici ça va
dépendre des applications que vous avez
qui sont déjà installés ça peut par
exemple être des notes ça peut être un
Samsung internet un petit reminder des
choses donc vous avez pas mal de
possibilités et l'idée je trouve très
très cool et puis regardez après ça se
fond dans le décor et c'est très très
sympa et il y a une autre nouveauté
widget qui apparaît ici c'est la
sélection intelligente je vous l'ai mise
juste ici en fait c'est votre smartphone
qui va vous proposer de façon proactive
qui va prendre vos usages qui va
comprendre ce que vous faites et qui va
venir vous proposer les applications qui
vous correspondront à un instant T donc
lui il va venir le mettre ici dans la
partie sélection intelligente de la même
manière ici regardez je fais un appui
long je peux venir créer une pile je
vais choisir j'en sais rien moi par
exemple chrome avec quelques petits
raccourcis hop là ça ça me va je clique
sur Ajouter et j'ai créé ici ma pile
avec d'un côté ma suggestion
intelligente et de l'autre côté et bien
mes favoris mes raccourcis et tout ce
que je vais mettre ici sixième nouveauté
c'est la gestion du multitâche regardez
je vous montre là par exemple j'ai
Youtube je prends deux doigts je pars du
bas je reviens là et là ça me propose
différentes applications que je vais
pouvoir venir lancer directement j'en
sais rien on va se dire qu'on va aller
sur Chrome par exemple je peux venir
jouer encore au Dino si je le souhaite
ici vous voyez j'ai qu'à appuyé et en
même temps je peux venir regarder des
vidéos bon comme je suis mauvais Audino
je perds et après vous venez moduler
directement votre fenêtre comme vous le
souhaitez et si vous voulez fermer en
bas vous pouvez venir fermer en bas donc
le truc est malin alors ça c'est
vraiment une nouveauté il faut venir
vous l'activer directement pour se faire
vous venez dans vos paramètres dans vos
paramètres vous allez au niveau de
fonction avancées vous allez sur le Lab
et vous venez activer glissement pour
écran fractionné c'est ça qui vous
permet de venir lancer des petites
applications très facilement il y a un
autre truc qui est aussi très cool que
vous pouvez venir découvrir ici et que
je vous conseille de venir faire vous
partez du haut là comme ça sur le côté
et vous venez mettre une fenêtre
flottante alors ni comme ça vous venez
la moduler vous pouvez venir vous
déplacer avoir accès à vos paramètres
donc l'idée plutôt cool et être
flottante vous pouvez ensuite venir
juste en bas et la supprimer ici alors
je vous montre vous venez dans fonction
avancée vous allez sur Lab et vous venez
activer ça glissement pour affichage
contextuel ça vous permet de partir sur
le côté et de venir mettre votre fenêtre
comme vous le voulez vous voyez je mets
la taille hop là je la mets comme ça
c'est pratique c'est sympa et comme ça
après je peux venir la déplacer très
facilement et avoir du picture une
piqûre la septième nouveauté elle se
passe du côté de toute l'application
photo alors ça me saoule nous a annoncé
qu'on avait une barre de zoom plus
simple très honnêtement je l'ai pas vu
parce que pour autant pouvoir le faire à
un doigt non je dois lever mon doigt à
chaque fois donc je suis pas convaincu
cette histoire ou alors il y a un truc
qui m'a échappé mais je suis pas sûr par
contre il y a un truc qui est très
marrant si vous pouvez venir ajouter un
filigrane alors on se dit qu'est-ce
qu'on va venir faire dans le filigrane
on s'en fout de mettre la marque du
smartphone non on peut aller plus loin
regardez je vous montre vous allez dans
vos paramètres de photo juste ici et
vous allez activer le filigrane une fois
dans le filigrane vous cliquez dessus là
vous pouvez mettre le nom du modèle
alors très honnêtement ça c'est le
Samsung Galaxy S22 ultra on s'en fout
mais vous pouvez venir l'éditer si par
exemple vous faites j'en sais rien moi
une photo fait un portrait pour
quelqu'un que vous aimez bien vous
mettez non vous voulez vous pouvez
mettre portrait de ma chérie voilà c'est
un peu qq con con mais on peut marquer
portrait de ma chérie donc lorsque je
fais une photo et bien apparaîtra sur ma
photo juste là portrait de ma chérie et
si je veux aller encore plus loin savoir
quel jour et quelle heure je l'ai fait
et bien je clique sur date et heure
voilà portrait de ma chérie telle date
tel jour à telle heure c'est très cucu
j'ai fait mais il y a plein de
possibilités vous pouvez même aller plus
loin vous pouvez également venir à
modifier la police ici roboro ça me
saoule Noto faites comme vous voulez
l'alignement à gauche au centre à droite
comme vous voulez voilà donc un truc un
peu marrant on peut venir détourner ici
la fonctionnalité entre nouveautés
également et bien lorsque vous venez
zoomer le téléobjectif prend en charge
la fonction nourriture vous pouvez venir
zoomer dans vos plats et puis le mode
single take a été simplifié plus simple
à utiliser et plus clair plus lisible
autre nouveauté qui est intéressant je
vous montre vous pouvez venir récupérer
des éléments à partir d'une photo que
vous avez fait par exemple ici à les
Pokémon je viens je fais une photo et
ensuite je vais dans ma photo et je vais
pouvoir cliquer ici pour extraire
directement des éléments de mon texte je
peux ensuite le copier je peux ensuite
le traduire je fais ce que je veux OK et
si par exemple ici je viens scanner un
numéro de téléphone et bien je vais
pouvoir l'appeler directement bon c'est
des petits raccourcis c'est plutôt
pratique la neuvième nouveauté elle se
fait du côté des notifications avec des
icônes qui seront plus grandes plus
lisibles vous voyez c'est quand même un
petit peu mieux que ce qu'on retrouvait
avant je trouve ça assez clair il y a
pas de grosse révolution mais c'est un
peu amélioré et lorsque vous allez venir
installer démarrer une application pour
la première fois elle vous demandera si
vous l'autoriser à vous envoyer des
notifications ou pas vous pouvez
également venir à bloquer les
notifications très facilement depuis les
paramètres et notifications et vous
choisissez comment vont s'afficher le
notification en pop-up en badge et sur
l'écran de verrouillage et ça je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure sur l'écran de
verrouillage 10e point c'est le centre
de bien-être numérique qui a été
amélioré pour être plus clair vous voyez
les applications que vous avez utilisées
vous avez pas mal d'informations ici la
11e nouveauté elle est aussi assez
rigolote si par exemple vous voulez
utiliser une application dans une langue
en particulier parce que je sais pas
vous êtes bilingue ça vous arrange
beaucoup vous comprenez mieux dans cette
langue et bien vous allez sur votre
application dans les paramètres et dans
Application et vous allez dans langue
juste ici vous cliquez dessus et vous
choisissez la langue alors moi il me
propose le Catala le français et après
je peux mettre ce que je veux donc si je
vais le mettre en anglais je peux le
mettre en anglais il y a également une
amélioration au niveau des paramètres de
son et vibrations qui sont regroupés
ensemble 12e nouveauté vous pouvez venir
désactiver la rame plus si vous savez
pas ce que c'est et bien votre téléphone
va pouvoir utiliser de la rom donc de
l'espace de stockage pour le transformer
en RAM pour apporter plus de fluidité à
votre téléphone et si vous voulez pas
que ça n'arrive si vous voulez garder le
stockage de disponible quoi qu'il arrive
et bien vous pouvez aller ici vous allez
batterie est maintenant de l'appareil
vous venez dans mémoire et vous allez
dans RAM plus juste en bas les momies 4
gigas je peux venir tout simplement le
désactiver ça c'était pas possible avant
bon c'est de la petite optimisation mais
si vous voulez le faire maintenant vous
pouvez le faire de la même manière dans
la maintenance de l'appareil à un
nouveau truc qui est aussi intéressant
c'est l'optimisation automatique en gros
si vous activez ça votre téléphone il
redémarrage lorsqu'il sent qu'il y a un
bein ce que ça va pas donc vous cochez
cette case là et votre smartphone
redémarrera tout simplement en cas de
besoin autre nouveauté au niveau de la
sécurité la partie sécurité est
confidentialité a été revue corrigée
avec un nouveau tableau de bord pour
venir paramétrer plus facilement la
sécurité sur votre smartphone allez je
vous montre la 15e elle est plutôt
rigolote je sais pas si elle servira
beaucoup vous venez dans votre horloge
et dans votre horloge vous avez la
possibilité de mettre 3 minutes heures
si vous dites par exemple je suis en
train de cuisiner assez con j'avais
qu'un minuteur par exemple je vais
mettre le des pâtes j'en sais rien moi
je veux bien aller mes pâtes en 8
minutes elles sont cuites al dente ça va
bien d'un autre côté je vais me dire bon
alors en même temps attends attends j'ai
le poulet le poulet c'est 1h15 parce que
je suis sur un kilo 5 allez je me fais
ça et puis de l'autre côté j'en sais
rien je suis en train de concasser des
tomates j'en sais foutrement rien vous
mettez ce que vous voulez tiens j'en
sais rien je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire en 20 minutes voilà en 20
minutes ben dans 20 minutes et bien je
dois faire ça je mets un minuteur donc
vous pouvez mettre 3 minutes heures à 4
minutes à 5 minutes mais bien 3 minutes
c'est déjà trois fois mieux qu'avant
voilà pour ces 15 nouveautés ici sur
votre smartphone de Samsung c'est one uy
5 alors le retour global que j'aurai
vous faire c'est que je trouve qu'ils
améliorent les choses ça devient un peu
plus joli c'est élégant il y a des
nouveautés qui sont là il y a pas de
très grosses révolution par rapport à ce
qu'on a pu voir arriver des fois par le
passé ce sont des petits ajouts sont des
améliorations que permet Android 13 je
continue à penser que Oney est une des
meilleures expériences aujourd'hui sur
Android j'aime beaucoup je trouve très
fluide elle fonctionne bien elle est
agréable on comprend très facilement les
paramètres c'est très bien structuré
très bien hiérarchisé donc ça fonctionne
pas de souci pas de mauvaise surprise on
vient juste améliorer on vient peaufiner
on vient rendre plus élégant ce qui
était déjà dans l'idée d'Android 12 qui
est encore plus originé d'Android 13 et
bien ici Samsung avec One ui 5 vient
confirmer sa copie et bien continuer à
l'améliorer on verra ce qui arrivera sur
one you i6 l'un des prochaines on a
encore vraiment le temps mais d'ici là
on reparlera de Samsung parce que d'ici
trois mois on devrait voir arriver les
Samsung Galaxy S23 ça sera très
intéressant avant ça on parlera encore
plein d'autres choses des astuces sur le
smartphone ici et ailleurs donc pensez à
venir vous abonner c'est pas déjà le cas
et puis dites-moi parmi les 15
fonctionnalités que je vous ai montré
parmi les 15 nouveautés laquelle vous
préférez que le mois juste en bas on
commentaire d'ici là je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]